the funeral for Iowa college student
Molly Tibbets will be held on Sunday
after an autopsy confirmed she was
murdered a preliminary report says the
20 year old died from multiple sharp
force injuries tippin's disappeared more
than a month ago while jogging drone
footage from our Des Moines affiliate
KCCI shows the area where her body was
found hey Jenna Diaz has new details on
the undocumented immigrant who lived
nearby and is charged with her murder
good morning we're told Tibbets injuries
were stab wounds from a sharp object but
we don't know what there are also many
questions about the suspect but we've
learned that he entered the u.s. as a
minor he has a 7th or 8th grade
education and he's a father
during the five-week search for Molly
Tibbets her accused killer Christian
bhajana Rivera reported to work everyday
at this dairy farm acting normally
that's according to this co-worker who
asked us to conceal her identity and I'm
not guessing that somebody would have
done something like this would be
nervous and not able to eat she said he
seemed like nothing was wrong do you
think he did that so stuck I know you
know why don't you know great kid no no
no way you want to believe that it
wasn't him she says Rivera who's an
undocumented immigrant from Mexico is
calm not violent and a good father she
says the suspect has a three year-old
daughter with his ex-girlfriend they
were at his hearing this week
Alan Richards is his lawyer he has he
expressed any kind of sadness I think
he's like anybody else it's it's just
it's hard to understand what happened
out on that road in the affidavit it
says he told investigators that he left
Molly's body in a cornfield I'm
reserving judgment on that issue until I
see the interrogation interview which
I'm assuming they have she was killed by
a horrible person that came in from
Mexico illegally here the case has
reignited calls for stronger immigration
laws the immigration laws are horrible
what do you think of the fact the
president is accusing undocumented
people in this no no debería que ser
porque personas Milazzo en toda la raza
so you're saying you don't agree with
that because there are bad people in all
races Rivera's lawyer disputes that he's
undocumented but didn't show us any
proof he says his client is innocent
until proven guilty the community is
still reeling one woman said their
innocence is gone
that was Adriana Diaz reporting from Des
Moines